[Music]
in conclusion a joke about time travel
but first the rest of everything I'm
going to say Buddhism big fan big fan of
Buddhism ordered a book on it it hasn't
arrived yet so I presume it's been
within me all this time first chapters
probably like get rid of all your
possessions in like way ahead of you
don't even have the book so bring it
Buddhists a thing they rarely hear I
like Buddhists because I've never heard
of them murdering everybody throughout
history like there's no historical like
Buddhist Inquisition or Buddhist
Crusades there's I don't never heard of
a Buddhist extremist like what would
that be just a guy taking a longer nap I
imagine look out suspicious I I'm not a
Buddhist I think I don't know could be
but I was raised Jewish not that Jewish
I'm this Jewish like I would run from
Hitler but that's about it
especially today I would definitely run
from Hitler today because he would be a
zombie today you should all run from
zombie Hitler Jew or not Jew you should
run from zombie Gandhi for that matter
run more from zombie Gandhi I would say
cuz he fasted during life he's probably
hungrier in death so look out the most
for zombie Gandhi also the name my
favorite new hipster band that does not
yet exist that toe cool I am so the
thing about time travel is if it exists
in the future we all know obviously Jews
are going to use it to go back and try
to kill Hitler before all the
shenanigans began perhaps a harsher word
than shenanigans having happened yet
Hitler still in our past I believe if
you know otherwise great but Hitler is
still there because it's not like Back
to the Future that's not how time travel
works it's you can't just go back and
screw everything up a great movie Back
to the Future great movie wrong about
time travel oh yeah
thanks for one of those you agree with
something I said thank you back to the
future at the end of Back to the Future
one which they didn't call that they
called it the great Back to the Future
at the end of that movie spoiler alert
it came out in 1985 you had a little
while to see it so Doc Brown flies up in
the time-machine carnies like Martin get
in quick we gotta go to the future your
kids they're in trouble
hurry even as a kid I remember thinking
like why do you have to hurry you have a
time machine
you you invented it you we're gonna be
late we'll just set it for earlier then
that's literally how it works you're a
doctor I hear they made three of those
movies they made one Groundhog Day sort
of a travesty
I feel like love ground dog they have a
friend George in New York who saw he
thought he saw Bill Murray on the
streets of New York he was like Bill
Murray
he yelled it at him and so that guy who
yelled at looked back and was like nope
and my friend George went home all said
he's like I thought it was Bill Murray
next day turns on the TV sees a talk
show Bill Murray's the guest it was that
guy it was exactly that guy's like man
so Bill Murray is such a great actor he
was able to convince my friend George
that he was not Bill Murray like
unbelievable Bill Murray oh thank you
thank you
thank you guys for clapping for how
great an actor I said Bill Murray was
what a great story what a story about
Bill Murray I just told you and about my
friend George why did I make it about
George could have been about me I could
have said I saw him but I'm not a liar
number one number two I don't want you
guys thinking I'm the kind of guy who
yells Bill Murray at Bill Murray I don't
do that I wouldn't do it if I thought
Bill Murray on the street I would yell
like Phil Phil Conners and then I'd run
around the block and yelled again
running on the block and yelled again
and again and again and again film it
Groundhog Day too so get another one of
those up on the board so that's not how
time travel works here's how I think it
does work I believe you can go back in
time you just can't change anything
physically you cannot like you go back
and try to shoot Hitler your gun will
jam cuz you didn't shoot Hitler the
first time around you were just there
with your gun jamming the whole time
maybe it's like terminator we can go
back but you can't bring weapons or
clothing through so a bunch of Jews are
just turning up naked in 1940's Germany
neither the time nor the place so even
if all that is the case even if Jews
know that they are doomed to never be
able to kill Hitler everyone in the
future they're gonna be resilient and
resourceful every Jew with access to a
time machine is going to go back and try
to complete this mission hundreds
thousands millions of Jews which means
that if that's the case then growing up
from Hitler's perspective Jews are just
trying to murder him all the time that's
all that child Hitler knows is that Jews
are dicks from the future
they are constantly coming out of the
woodwork throwing columns and knives
shooting lasers taking off his moustache
probably that's why that happened
because he is barely able to get out of
the way he's failing the matrix out like
a neo-nazi if you will
[Applause]